Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
"L'immaginazione è più importante
della conoscenza."
La conoscenza è limitata;
con l'immaginazione,
possiamo fare il giro del mondo.
Quando ero bambino,
la cosa che amavo di più fare
era usare planisferi e cartine geografiche
per scoprire il mondo.
Usavo l'immaginazione come ascensore
tra il mio piccolo paesino,
ai piedi delle montagne del Veneto,
e le città del mondo.
Volevo scoprire le città del mondo,
volevo andare in tutti i continenti;
e sognavo di vivere in tutti e cinque.
Vi immaginate che esperienza?
Poi, tra i banchi di scuola
ho sviluppato il mio primo vero sogno,
cioè quello di fare
il piccione viaggiatore.
Cioè trovare un lavoro
che mi permettesse di andare
in giro per il mondo, con la valigetta,
e conoscere persone, culture,
modo di fare impresa.
Nei primi dieci anni
di carriera lavorativa,
ho partecipato a 200 missioni
commerciali internazionali,
toccando 50 città in quattro continenti.
Poi, un giorno, mi sono domandato
se ero felice a fare quello che facevo.
La risposta non è stata completamente sì,
per cui ho deciso di lasciare quel lavoro,
lasciare il mio primo sogno
e lasciare anche la città dove vivevo.
Grazie a un amico -
un po' casualmente - dell'epoca,
mi sono trovato in California
a sviluppare il mio primo
progetto imprenditoriale.
Tutto nasce dal fatto che era il 2004.
Io avevo 27 anni, ed ero appena stato
in California per una vacanza.
Avevo percorso la mitica 101,
quella strada costiera
che ci porta dal Sud, da Los Angeles,
al nord, a San Francisco.
Amavo il gelato: e naturalmente,
nelle varie tappe
provavo il gelato americano.
Così, a un certo punto
ai miei compagni di viaggio ho detto:
Ma sai cosa?
Perché non portiamo il gelato italiano
in California, e lo vendiamo in America?
La mia, tutto sommato,
era un'idea analogica,
frutto del fatto che, fino ad allora,
il mio concetto di impresa
e di imprenditorialità
era legato alla manifattura,
quello per cui avevo lavorato
fino ad allora.
Ma l'America, e soprattutto la California,
in quel momento storico
era l'epicentro dell'intangibile:
della new economy,
del digitale, delle start up.
Pensate che: nel 1994 era nata Amazon;
nel '98 Google;
in quell'anno, 2004, nasceva Facebook;
addirittura, due anni dopo
sarebbe nata Twitter.
Io ero davanti al mio primo
fallimento imprenditoriale,
proprio nella terra che del fallimento
fa un messaggio positivo, quasi:
cioè, se fallisci è solo l'anticamera
di un possibile successo futuro.
Sono tornato da quel viaggio
innamorato delle startup,
e ho ripreso da lì il mio percorso.
Ma cosa sono, poi, queste startup?
E quante sono?
Pensate che, dai dati che abbiamo,
oggi parliamo di circa
150.000 startup al mondo.
Le startup raccolgono, ogni anno,
qualcosa come 500 miliardi di dollari
in investimenti privati.
Ci sono almeno 100 quotazioni in Borsa
di startup all'anno.
E soprattutto,
se le startup del mondo fossero uno Stato,
con circa quattro trilioni
di dollari di valore
potrebbero sedere al tavolo del G7.
Nel 2021, di queste 150.000 startup
è stato registrato il fatto
che 1200 valessero
più di un miliardo di dollari.
Vengono chiamate unicorni.
53 di loro valgono
dieci miliardi di dollari, o di più;
vengono chiamate decacorni.
Noi siamo abituati a pensare
che la Silicon Valley sia l'epicentro
delle startup nel mondo.
Invece, se guardiamo più da vicino,
ci accorgiamo che ci sono
almeno 150 altri territori,
città e territori in giro per il mondo
che sono stati capaci di attrarre
queste aziende innovative ad alto impatto.
E cosa succede se arriva una pandemia,
l'economia globale rallenta,
le città vanno al collasso?
Succede che le start up crescono
2,3 volte le aziende tradizionali,
attraggono i migliori talenti,
li ritengono
perché sono resilienti, veloci
e governano le tecnologie esponenziali.
Nel 2020,
quando questo shock esogeno,
chiamato CoVid19,
è arrivato nelle nostre città,
nelle nostre famiglie,
io lavoravo per una città
di circa 1.000.000 di abitanti, Torino.
E ricordo che, quando è arrivata
questa ondata improvvisa
che ha spazzato via, quasi,
i vecchi paradigmi,
il modo di lavorare,
l'agenda istituzionale,
e ha introdotto la necessità
di usare delle nuove munizioni
per uscire di casa la mattina,
composte dal fatto che bisognava
reagire alla contingenza,
ai bisogni delle famiglie, dei bambini,
delle scuole, degli anziani,
per fare questo
non era più necessario
guardare ai fornitori
e guardare all'impostazione tradizionale.
Era necessario trovare
qualche nuovo escamotage,
qualche nuova strategia
per poter ribattere
a questa situazione molto grave.
E la strategia è anche stata il fatto
di abbracciare nuove tecnologie,
tecnologie emergenti,
e dare più spazio a startup.
Pensate che uno dei progetti
più interessanti
che all'epoca abbiamo sviluppato
è stata una chiamata alle armi
di tutte le aziende partner della città
che si occupavano di tecnologia.
L'abbiamo chiamata "Torino City Love:
l'amore per l'innovazione
da parte di una città".
Hanno risposto in tanti,
a questa chiamata alle armi.
In dieci settimane,
le prime dieci settimane
del lockdown di marzo,
a partire da marzo 2020,
abbiamo messo insieme
100 microprogetti gratuiti
per famiglie, cittadinanza,
scuole, RSA, bambini.
E pensate che,
di questi 100 microprogetti,
circa metà di questi
sono stati resi possibili
grazie a startup.
Allora, le startup
cosa ci hanno permesso di fare?
Per esempio, ci hanno permesso
di andare in un reparto di lungodegenza,
di un ospedale infantile,
e portare lì la telepresenza
per aiutare i bambini
a sentirsi meno soli.
Ci hanno permesso di andare
al lato opposto della generazione,
cioè andare in 40 RSA,
e portare la telepresenza
affinché gli ospiti
si potessero sentire meno soli.
Ma allora, le startup
possono essere utili alle città?
Io direi di più.
Le città hanno bisogno delle startup,
perché dalle startup possono imparare
a reagire a delle curve,
a delle ondate tecnologiche
e anche ad eventuali
shock futuri che arriveranno.
E vi dico una cosa in più:
le città del futuro, secondo me,
saranno più simili a startup
che alle città di oggi.
E perché vi dico questo?
Vi dico questo perché,
nel momento in cui parliamo,
tutte le città del mondo
stanno affrontando delle sfide
e delle transizioni epocali.
Queste sfide e transizioni,
che necessitano trasformazione,
sono spesso alimentate o accelerate
da tecnologie esponenziali.
Pensate che l'Imperial College
di Londra, qualche anno fa,
ha pubblicato una sorta
di tavola periodica
delle 100 tecnologie esponenziali
che da qui ai prossimi 20 anni
"colpiranno", in senso buono,
le nostre città e la nostra società.
In queste tecnologie troviamo
dei nomi, delle nomenclature come:
Internet del DNA;
membri di un CdA robot;
scudi invisibili; ascensori spaziali,
edifici che assorbono l'inquinamento;
telepatia, tanto per citarne alcuni.
Che caratteristiche hanno
queste 100 tecnologie esponenziali?
Arrivano come delle onde alte:
per cui, per poterle navigare
bisogna essere scaltri, veloci,
esponenziali nella loro adozione.
I cittadini consumatori - noi -
abbiamo dimostrato,
negli ultimi decenni, di saperlo fare.
Pensate che, se guardiamo
al secolo scorso,
il telefono, cioè l'innovazione
e la tecnologia del telefono,
ci ha messo circa 30 anni
per raggiungere il 40%
di tasso di adozione delle famiglie.
I social media ci hanno messo il 10%
a raggiungere il doppio.
Questo significa che,
in una sorta di evoluzione della specie,
l'uomo cittadino consumatore
è diventato scaltro, bravo, veloce
ad adottare le tecnologie esponenziali.
Le città, per loro definizione,
sono più lente dei loro
cittadini ad adottarle:
ci mettono qualche anno in più.
Ci mettono qualche anno in più
per una serie di caratteristiche loro:
anche di costrizioni, se vogliamo.
Pertanto, se guardiamo a questa dinamica
alla luce di quanto abbiamo appena detto,
ci troviamo di fronte a questo problema,
quantomeno a una domanda
a cui trovare risposta.
Le città hanno una capacità lineare
di adottare tecnologie esponenziali;
noi, i loro cittadini, esponenziale.
Questo, alla lunga, crea un divario:
un divario che crea delle aspettative,
da entrambi i lati, differenti.
Noi cittadini ci aspettiamo
un certo tipo di reazione,
di fronte a un bisogno;
le città ci rispondono
in maniera più analogica, magari,
in maniera differente.
Come facciamo a colmare questo gap?
Non abbiamo una risposta
preconfezionata, oggi:
però possiamo osservare
i primi della classe,
cioè quelle città che stanno cercando
di ridurre questa distanza,
e diventare più veloci e più abili
ad adottare tecnologie dirompenti.
Come fanno queste città?
Se guardiamo un po' degli esempi virtuosi
in giro per il mondo,
osserviamo che queste città
stanno imparando
dai soggetti più veloci del mercato
a governare queste tecnologie -
per definizione, le startup:
stanno imparando da loro
una serie di tecniche per farlo.
Ci sono tre ingredienti, in particolare,
che le città stanno adottando,
le città più virtuose.
Il primo è legato alle sperimentazioni.
Cioè le città diventano dei luoghi
dove sperimentare tecnologie esponenziali.
Mettono a disposizione il loro territorio
alle startup e ad innovatori
di tutto il mondo
per testare lì, in loco,
le loro tecnologie.
Il secondo ingrediente è dato
dall'ecosistema innovazione:
la città, da sola,
non ha le competenze, le risorse, la forza
di rispondere a queste ondate,
che abbiamo detto essere delle onde alte,
e anche molto veloci,
e molto forti, e ad alto impatto.
Pertanto, hanno bisogno
di mettersi attorno
una costellazione di attori
che le possano aiutare.
Il terzo ingrediente è dato
dalla cultura imprenditoriale:
le città, e i sindaci di queste città,
stanno cercando di attrarre
più startup possibili
perché da loro, insieme a loro,
hanno più forza a dominare
queste ondate di tecnologie esponenziali.
E cosa succede se una città
comincia a copiare, ad imparare
e a diventare più simile a una startup?
Beh, nel 2021 sono nati
due unicorni in media al giorno,
più 50% rispetto all'anno precedente.
Queste aziende,
che oramai sono distribuite
in 170 città nel mondo,
sono aziende che possono portare
un alto valore, e un alto impatto,
alla cittadinanza e al territorio.
Attraggono talenti, li ritengono,
cioè hanno la capacità di tenerli
e farli crescere ed evolvere,
e hanno la capacità di interpretare
il lavoro del futuro -
un lavoro più distribuito, più liquido -
in maniera più efficace.
La città startup può ambire
a diventare, forse, una città unicorno;
e creare valore, essere più competitiva
per il suo territorio
e per i suoi cittadini.
Come siamo messi in Italia?
Beh, se guardiamo i dati più recenti
a cui abbiamo accesso pubblicamente,
in Italia troviamo
che ci sono dieci territori,
e la buona notizia
è che sono abbastanza distribuiti
nella nostra penisola,
che sono stati in grado di attrarre
la più grande quantità
di aziende innovative,
le cosiddette startup innovative
iscritte al registro delle imprese.
C'è un trend positivo,
c'è un trend in crescita:
anche se l'Italia vale, ancora,
meno dell'un percento
di investimenti in startup
a livello globale.
Ora, se torniamo alla frase
e alla citazione con cui ho iniziato,
che parlava di conoscenza e immaginazione,
e che è una famosa citazione
di Albert Einstein,
quella frase poteva essere, al massimo,
stata detta nel 1955.
In quell'anno lì, la popolazione mondiale
era di poco più alta
di 2,5 miliardi di individui.
Siamo cresciuti ad un tasso medio
di 80 milioni di unità
negli scorsi decenni.
E oggi, alla soglia degli otto miliardi,
ci stiamo proiettando
verso una popolazione mondiale
che toccherà i 10 miliardi intorno al 2050
e che vedrà sette miliardi su dieci -
quindi 70%: oggi siamo al 55% -
di persone che vivono in città.
Queste persone,
questi sette miliardi di persone,
nel 2050,
dopo che le 100 tecnologie esponenziali
saranno arrivate,
saranno state messe a terra,
che città si aspetteranno?
Probabilmente, si aspetteranno delle città
come case delle tecnologie emergenti,
ovvero città che hanno assorbito
in maniera positiva le tecnologie,
dal 5G all'intelligenza artificiale,
ai sensori e ai droni,
auto connesse autonome e molte altre,
a beneficio dei cittadini
e non per creare
spauracchi per i cittadini.
Gli ingredienti per costruire
delle città del futuro
partono proprio
dalle tecnologie esponenziali.
E le città del futuro
vorranno attrarre attorno a sé
più startup possibili,
proprio per quello
che abbiamo detto prima:
riuscire a navigare in maniera più sicura
queste onde alte
delle tecnologie esponenziali.
Avremo bisogno di conoscenza
e di immaginazione,
per creare queste città;
e questa è sicuramente una sede
in cui possiamo metterne assieme tanta.
Le città del futuro, in fondo,
saranno simili alle start up:
o forse, saranno solo
eguali e diseguali tra di loro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)